nobody is their dysfunction that's not  who anybody is nobody is a victim nobody  is an addict that's not who anybody is  when people say i have a disease i have  multiple sclerosis or i have depression  or i have addiction i don't talk about  it that way anymore  because there's an implicit assumption  in that way of languaging things to say  that i have an addiction  or even to say that i am an addict  assumes that there's this thing called  an addiction then there's me and i have  this thing  this thing is not  about me somehow just something that i  have the addiction is not a separate  thing that i have it's a process that's  happening inside me which means that if  i change the process  i have a way of affecting  this thing that we call disease or  addiction  or anything else